dt no c 2 h 4 con una masa molar de 28.1
gramos por mol se puede preparar
mediante la deshidratación del etanol se
2h 5 h cuya masa molar es de 46.1 gramos
por mol usando un catalizador sólido en
el diagrama de arriba se muestra la
instalación para la síntesis de
laboratorio la ecuación para la reacción
de deshidratación es tratada a
continuación entonces tenemos el etanol
en presencia de un catalizador y vamos a
producir este no y agua y aquí tenemos
algunos datos para esa reacción
un estudiante agregó 0.2 cientos de una
muestra de etanol
este es el etanol de 2 h 5 o h a un tubo
de ensayo usando la instalación que se
muestra arriba entonces esta es una lana
de vidrio con etanol aquí está el
y aquí tenemos un catalizador sólido
el estudiante calentó lentamente el tubo
de ensayo con un mechero de ponce hasta
que todo el etanol se evaporó y la
generación de gas se detuvo entonces
aquí tenemos el calentamiento y cuando
todo el etanol que tenemos se evapora la
generación de gas se detiene cuando la
reacción se detuvo el volumen de gas
recolectado fue de 0.0 854 litros a 0.8
cientos 22 atmósferas y 305 kelvin la
presión de vapor del agua a 305 kelvin
es de 35.7 thor entonces en presencia de
este catalizador el etanol va a
reaccionar para que con la reacción de
deshidratación podamos producir este no
y agua así que enfriamos y capturamos lt
no en esta parte porque se encontrará en
estado gaseoso y el agua saldrá en forma
de vapor de agua
después de enfriar se quedará aquí en
forma de agua líquida entonces tratemos
de responder las preguntas calcula el
número de moles de té no 1 que se
producen en el experimento y se miden en
el tubo de recolección del gas y 2 que
se producirían si la reacción de
deshidratación se completará inciso b
calcula el porcentaje de rendimiento de
teno en el experimento ok
empecemos con la parte 1 de alguna forma
tenemos que saber cuántos moles se
producen en el experimento y se miden en
el tubo de recolección del gas entonces
que nos están dando aquí vamos a ver nos
dicen que hasta que todo el etanol se
evaporó y la generación de gas se detuvo
fue cuando la reacción se detuvo y el
volumen del gas este volumen de gas es
el volumen de teno que tenemos aquí así
que nuestro volumen de gas fue de 0.0
854 litros
1.822 atmósferas entonces esta es la
presión total y la temperatura es de 305
kelvin y también nos dan la presión de
vapor del agua que es de 35.7 thor a 305
kelvin así que la presión de vapor la
podemos ver como la presión parcial del
agua y esto nos sirve mucho porque la
presión parcial del agua más la presión
parcial de lete no nos dan la presión
total que ya tenemos aquí así que
podemos usar esta información para
conocer la presión parcial de lete no y
conociendo la presión parcial de lete no
entonces podemos usar la ley de los
gases ideales para saber cuántos moles
de teno tenemos
aquí y cómo lo hacemos bueno como un
pequeño recordatorio de la ley de los
gases ideales tenemos que la presión que
en este caso estamos hablando de la
presión parcial de lete no la presión
parcial de lete no por el volumen
también nos da en el volumen es igual al
número de moles por la constante de los
gases por la temperatura entonces ya
tenemos la presión bueno ya sabemos cómo
calcular conocemos el volumen también
conocemos la constante de los gases y
bueno no necesitan memorizar todo esto
aquí he copiado y pegado lo que les dan
en la parte delantera de un examen ap
así que no necesitan memorizar todas las
constantes miren aquí tenemos la
constante de los gases ideales con los
valores en distintas unidades
dependiendo de la que necesitemos usar y
claro también conocemos la temperatura
que es de 305 kelvin entonces si quieren
es calcular el número de moles
simplemente podemos dividir ambos lados
de la ecuación entre rt y así nos queda
que n es igual a si dividimos ambos
lados entre r t n es igual a pp que en
este caso p es la presión parcial de
lete no
por el volumen entre r t r t ok vamos a
ver cuál será la presión parcial de led
en o bueno la presión parcial de lete no
es igual a la presión total menos la
presión parcial o presión de vapor del
agua y esto es igual a la presión total
es igual a cero punto 822 atmósferas
entonces 0.8 cientos 22 atmósferas
y cuál es la presión parcial del agua
nos dicen que la presión de vapor del
agua a 305 kelvin es de 35.7 torre pero
observen que la presión total está en
atmósferas así que necesitamos convertir
estos thor en atmósferas lo haré por acá
entonces la presión parcial del agua es
igual a 35.7 thor que también es una
unidad de presión y para convertir en
atmósferas recuerden que no tienen que
memorizar sé todo esto porque se los dan
en el examen aquí nos dicen que una
atmósfera es igual a 760 thor entonces
como queremos deshacernos de los tor y
queremos que todo quede en atmósferas y
ya sabemos que una atmósfera es igual a
760 thor
esto es igual a 35.7 / 760 vamos a ver
35.7 por una atmósfera que es igual a
760 thor entonces entre 760 actor es
igual a y tomando en cuenta tres cifras
significativas es igual a cero punto
cero 470 0.0 470 entonces esto es igual
a cero punto cero 470 atmósferas
entonces la presión total menos la
presión parcial del agua que es de 0.0
470 atmósferas es igual al
simplemente podemos hacer que esto sea
negativo y sumar la presión total
entonces + 0 punto 822 la presión
parcial de led en o tomando en cuenta
tres cifras significativas es igual a
cero punto 775 entonces es igual a cero
punto 775 ahora sí ya podemos sustituir
este valor y como ya conocemos todo
podemos calcular el número de moles
entonces n es igual a cero punto 775
atmósferas siempre hay que revisar que
tengamos las unidades
entonces atmósferas por el volumen que
nos dicen que es de 0.0 854 litros
entonces
0.0 854 litros
y todo esto entre rt pero que el valor
de erre usamos bueno como estamos
trabajando en atmósferas moles y kelvin
podemos usar este pero por ejemplo si
hubiéramos preferido convertir la
presión a thor entonces usaríamos este
entonces nuestra r es igual a cero punto
cero 82 0-6 aquí son más cifras
significativas y eso no es problema pero
al final en el resultado
solamente tomaremos en cuenta tres
cifras significativas porque es lo que
estamos usando 33 aunque aquí sean más
de 3 aquí son cuatro cifras
significativas ok y vamos a asegurarnos
de que nuestras unidades sean
consistentes
aquí tenemos litros por atmósferas que
se van a cancelar con estas entre y no
olviden que estamos en el denominador
moles por qué
y esto lo vamos a multiplicar por la
temperatura que es igual a 305 kelvin
kelvin entonces vamos a ver estas
atmósferas se cancelan con estas
atmósferas estos litros se cancelan con
estos litros éstos kelvin se cancelan
con estos kelvin y por lo tanto como en
el denominador estamos dividiendo entre
moles las unidades que nos quedan al
final son moles ok y todo esto es igual
a redoble de tambores por favor esto es
igual a cero punto 775 atmósferas por
0.0 854 litros entre 0.0 82 0-6 que es
igual a eso entre 305 que es igual a amd
tomando en cuenta tres cifras
significativas es igual a 0.00 264
entonces esto es aproximadamente igual a
0.00 264 moles
está bien
a veces tengo mala memoria 0.00 264
60.000 264 moles ahí lo tienen esa es la
primera parte este es el número de moles
de teno que se producen en el
experimento y se miden en el tubo de
recolección del gas